so senator Sanders you're gonna run for
president I am going to run for
president that's correct
what's gonna be different this time
we're gonna win
we are gonna also launch what I think is
unprecedented in modern American history
and that is a grassroots movement John
to lay the groundwork for transforming
the economic and political life of this
country that's what's different and
that's your theory which is that without
the groundswell without the grassroots
you can't change the politic that's
exactly right look young somebody can
come before you and say look I want to
do a and I want to do B and that's fine
but at the end of the day the only way
that real change takes place is when
millions of people stand up fight back
and say enough is enough we're gonna
have a government that works for all of
us not just a few but bottom line for me
is I think it is absolutely imperative
that Donald Trump are be defeated
because I think it is unacceptable and
unamerican to be frank with you that we
have a president who is a pathological
liar and it gives me no pleasure to say
that but it's true we have a president
who is a racist who is a sexist who is a
xenophobe who was doing what no
president in our lifetimes has come
close to doing and that is trying to
divide us up but all of your opponents
will say we've gotta get Donald Trump
out of the White House that's not your
distinguishing characteristic so that is
not my distinguishing characteristic I
think what I am very proud of in a sense
this campaign
John is a continuation of what we did in
2016 you will recall you may recall that
in 2016
many of the ideas that I talked about
Medicare for all raising the minimum
wage to $15 an hour making public
colleges and universities tuition-free
all of those ideas people was all Bernie
they're so radical they are extremely
American people just won't accept those
ideas well you know what's happened that
over three years all of those ideas and
many more are now part of the political
mainstream so you're saying the party
came your way well I don't want to say
that I think most people would say that
is that your argue
then against your competitors which is I
was Medicare for all before Medicare for
always cool haha I guess that's one way
of looking at but it's no I know many of
the people certainly the senators who
are running and without exception I am
fond of them there are some cases my
friends let me ask you on your Medicare
for all you have talked about the fact
that polls show seventy percent are in
favor of Medicare for all but that
number drops to thirty seven if somebody
hears private insurance is going to go
away which is what your which is what
your plan offers so I guess my question
is your offering something that the
polling shows people can get very spook
very quickly no well but that's because
we're going to be taking on the
insurance companies and the drug
companies we're gonna spend a whole lot
of money distorting what we believe in
the bottom line is the average middle
class family will save money will spend
less money on health care will have more
choice and have broader coverage than
it's currently the case the other
challenge to your health care plan will
be cost people will say my goodness
there's no way this is everybody's gonna
get covered and there are the estimates
help us explain the truth no more
out-of-pocket expenses
no more deductibles the cost of
prescription drugs is going to go down
we expand the kinds of coverage
available for senior citizens it's a
good deal Howard Schultz has now said he
would not run as an independent if the
Democrats moderate why is Howard Schultz
on every television station in this
country why are you quoting how it shows
because he's a billionaire all right
there are a lot of people I know
personally who work hard for a living
and make forty fifty thousand dollars
eeeh who know a lot more about politics
than all due respect as mr. Schultz but
because we have a corrupt political
system anybody who is a billionaire who
can throw a lot of TV ads on television
suddenly becomes very very credible
so what mr. Schultz what is he
blackmailing the Democratic Party if you
don't nominate Bernie Sanders he's not
going to run well I don't think we
should succumb to that kind of blackmail
the other reason is that he represents
an argument that some people make which
is if you're worried about Donald Trump
the Democratic Party to win voters
various parts of the country needs to
pick somebody who is not so radical
that's also what his theory well I think
his deeper theory is hey I'm a
billionaire leave me alone and let me
make as much money as I can without
paying my fair share of taxes he's a
billionaire it's like I'm running for
president something's a very famous guy
that's that is a problem with our
political system